SPEAKER: Please welcome to
the stage two time record
holder and all around
cool guy, Colin O'Brady.
[APPLAUSE]
COLIN O'BRADY: Word for
word how I asked for it.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Thank you guys for being here.
It's fantastic to be here today.
I'm going to take you guys
on a bit of a journey.
So last year I set
two world records,
something called the
Explorers Grand Slam.
So I climbed the
tallest mountain
on each of the seven continents
to go to the north and south
pole.
This is from Carstensz
Pyramid, which
is the tallest mountain in
the Australasia continent.
We'll get into that, obviously.
Going over a tiny little
piece of rope with 2,000 feet
drop offs on either side
is enough to get the heart
pounding right away.
But before we get
into all of that,
I want to take you
guys back a little bit.
Because about 10, 11
years ago, my life
looked nothing like any of this.
Just after I graduated
from college in 2006,
I took a backpack
and a surfboard
and decided to head off in
the world for an adventure
with no itinerary
and found myself
on a beach in rural Thailand.
And of course, because I was
22 years old and invincible,
this looked like a great
activity to partake in.
Yes, that's a flaming jump rope.
And as you can probably tell,
it did not go very well for me.
So the rope wrapped
around my legs,
lit my body completely
on fire to my neck.
The ocean was a few
steps away, so kind of
with one last breath and ounce
of courage, I ran to the ocean,
dove into the ocean to
extinguish the flames,
but not before this happened,
which is I had been severely,
severely burned.
I won't make you stare
at that for too long.
But what must have
been at least,
I don't know, 24
hours or so later,
I awoke leaving a small ICU.
And there was placed in
the surgery room in ICU
where there was a cat
running around my bed
and across my chest, which
was certainly hammering home
the fact that I was
very, very, very
far from home and in a
dire set of circumstances.
Certainly this unsanitary
hospital could kill me.
And I don't know,
but even worse,
they were giving me a ton
of morphine at the time.
But I don't know if anyone has
had morphine in a hospital?
Maybe?
It's not that fun.
It kind of feels like there's
insects crawling over your skin
and it's horrible.
So just a terribly
traumatic experience for me,
and I was really
downward spiraling quick.
And I was in the
middle of nowhere
on a small island in
Thailand, and they
couldn't move me because it was
really too intense for that.
So luckily for me, about
five days in this ordeal,
I ended up having
eight surgeries
eight days in a row in this
small hospital, my mom arrived
to my bedside to
be my protector.
And so I know now
that she was crying
every single day in the hallways
and pleading with the doctors.
But she instead everyday
came into my hospital room
with a smile on her face,
an air of positivity,
daring me to dream
about the future.
Saying things to
me like, "Colin,
what do you want to do
when you get out of here?
Let's set a goal."
And me being 22 years old
at the time, I was like,
are you kidding me, mom?
I'm screwed.
My life is over.
The doctors every
day were telling me
that I would never walk again
normally because my legs had
been so badly burned over
the ligaments, the knee
and ankle joints, where
the mobility was really
never supposed to return.
And so it was a dire set
of circumstances for me.
But she really kept at
me every single day,
forcing me to think
about the future.
So finally, kind of buying
into her positivity,
I said all right mom, one
day when I get out of here,
I'm going to one day
race a triathlon.
So that was my big goal.
And looking down at
my legs at the time
seemed rather unrealistic.
I'd also never done that before.
I'd never done a triathlon.
But in my mind, that's
what's a strong sort
of able-bodied person could do.
And so before I knew it, I
actually asked this doctor.
He kind of has a crazy
coy look on his face
because I said, all right, I'm
training for a triathlon now.
Here I am.
I'm burned, I'm in Thailand.
And I had them bring
in some weights
for me to start kind of
working my arms out, just
to get something
going on for me.
But really that goal
gave me a purpose.
And so it was several
more weeks until I
was released from
that Thai hospital
and flown back to Portland,
Oregon, which is my hometown.
And I still hadn't even taken
a single step at that point.
So I was carried on
and off the plane
and placed in a wheelchair
when I got home.
And the next morning, I
awoke in my mother's kitchen,
and my mom said to me, she
says, "All right, Colin, now I
know you've got this
big triathlon goal.
That's great.
But today your goal is
to take one single step."
And so she grabbed this
chair and placed it one step
in front of my wheelchair.
She said, you need
to figure out how
to get out of your
wheelchair and get
into that chair in front of you.
It took me three hours that
day to work up the courage
and strength to do that.
But somehow, someway, I
got out of my wheelchair
and sat in that chair.
And the next day she moved the
chair five steps away from me,
and the next day 10.
Each day I could take
a few more steps.
Ever present in my mind
was this triathlon goal
of getting back to my fitness.
And a little shot of me.
I was a swimmer as a kid and
I was a collegiate swimmer
at Yale before all this
burn accident happened.
So I was just kind
of figuring, how
can I get back to being
able to move my body?
I remember the day after I
could walk a little bit, months
into this, and then
one day I could jog.
Jogging felt like
flying that day,
but it certainly was
a far cry from being
able to run any
sort of triathlon.
So it took another 18 months
until I had a shot at actually
taking a shot at my goal.
But about a year and a
half after my accident,
I had taken a job in Chicago
in the financial industry,
and I signed up for
the Chicago triathlon.
So about a year and a half, like
I said, after my burn accident,
I honored my goal by
diving into Lake Michigan
and swimming a mile for
the start of the triathlon
and then getting on my
bike, riding at 25 miles,
and then putting
my running shoes on
and running to the finish line.
Crossing that finish line for
me was a very joyous moment,
having honored that goal that
I set in a Thai hospital to
not only walk again.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And then there was one
other crazy surprise
in store for me that day.
I hadn't just finished
the race, but I actually
had won the entire
Chicago triathlon.
Beating out about over 4,000
other participants on the day
certainly was a
crazy moment for me.
And although the win was
certainly a nice cherry on top,
the first thing I thought about
were those moments in the Thai
hospital and wondering
what would have happened
had my mom not forced me
to set a measurable goal
and to keep moving forward.
And I had learned this, to
me, a really invaluable lesson
that I've taken with me through
the next decade of my life,
which was that life
is going to test us
with setbacks, no
matter who we are.
But we have every opportunity
to choose to keep moving forward
one step at a time.
I'd also learned that we
all as humans, not just me,
but everyone, has reservoirs
of untapped potential inside
of us, and can
achieve great things.
But quite often, the biggest
thing standing in our way
is our own minds.
And so this opened up a whole
new sort of pathway for me
in my life, which allowed
me to go quit my finance
job the next day and become a
professional triathlete, which
is far less lucrative than
the financial industry,
but it allowed me the
opportunity to race
in 25 countries on six different
continents over the next six
years, which was an amazing
period of life for me.
And I'd always kind
of dreamed of being
a professional athlete.
Not as glamorous as the
NBA or something like that,
but amazing
experience nonetheless
that I really cherished.
And then in the fall of 2014, so
I guess almost three years ago
now, I found myself
here, which was
at the summit of Ecuador's third
tallest mountain with a diamond
ring in my pocket, asking my
longtime girlfriend, Jenna,
to marry me.
And I joke with
her, I don't know
if it was the altitude
in her brain at the time,
but luckily she did say yes.
And we got engaged on
top of this mountaintop.
And it was around the same
time that racing and triathlon
was going well for us, for me.
But we are embarking on a
new piece of life together
and we really wanted to set
some new goals together.
And we both love
this Emerson quote
which goes, "Unless you try to
do something beyond what you've
already mastered,
you will never grow."
So I'm sure a bunch of
Googlers in this room,
you're very familiar
with that growth mindset
or thinking about innovation
and creative ideas.
So I'm a big believer
in that as well.
And so in this phase of
time, we said, what's
a big goal that we want to set?
What do we really care about?
What's meaningful to us?
So I being an athlete was really
committed to pushing my body,
but wanted to build
something that
had a larger arc
to it that could
have a great impact
in the community.
So we decided that
I would attempt
to set the world record for
something called the Explorers
Grand Slam, with
the larger purpose
of founding a nonprofit
to inspire kids everywhere
to move their bodies, to
dream big, to set goals,
to live active
and healthy lives.
So I mentioned it when
I first started this,
but I'll review quickly what the
Explorers Grand Slam entails.
But that entails climbing
the seven summits.
So that's the tallest
mountain on each of the seven
continents, as well as
completing expeditions to both
the North and South pole.
Fewer than 50 people
in history have ever
completed the Grand Slam.
Most people take
five or 10 years
to train for a big expedition
like Everest or Denali,
then come home, plan and
train for the next one.
I was going to attempt to
break the world records,
so be the fastest to
consecutively do all of that.
So from start to finish, no
breaks, no rest in between,
climb one mountain, fly to the
next place, climb the next one.
So that was our bigger purpose.
And like I said, we
founded a nonprofit.
So our nonprofit is by
the name of Beyond 72.
So for the seven peaks
and two mountains,
but that this whole idea
was beyond me in this,
but using sort of the
media and story around this
to tell stories and get early
in the curriculum of classrooms.
Today's kids are the
least active in history.
I was fortunate to
grow up around parents,
my dad's an organic
farmer and my mother
works in the natural
foods grocery industry,
so I had some great influences
in terms of health and wellness
in my life.
I'm sure everyone in
this room is aware
that's not true of a large
amount of our population.
So really trying to spread
that positive message
around wellness and how
wellness can contribute
to positive growth in
any aspects of life,
not just being an
athlete, but in terms
of academic pursuits,
career, anything
like that in the long run.
So we really brought our
message all around to schools.
And it started as a small
thing, but as you'll see,
it grows and grows throughout
the course of this journey.
Similar to many of you
who are, of course,
thinking of great,
exciting ideas
here at Google, which
are probably well
beyond my capacity to even
dream up, we had this big dream,
but we didn't have any
funding to do the project,
we didn't know
anything about PR,
we didn't know anything
about branding, marketing.
We didn't know anything
about founding a nonprofit.
So this really started as
just that, simply an idea.
And so for the next 18 months,
before I even started out
on any of the mountains,
I remember the moment
when we Googled, what is
the difference between PR
and marketing?
It's a very
rudimentary question,
but we actually didn't
know the difference.
But again, as we'll
see, this does grow.
And we learned along the
way, after a year and a half,
we finally did raise this
necessary sponsorship.
We founded a nonprofit, kind of
turned this dream into reality,
trying to figure out all
the different nuances
of all the many places
we need to go to.
And Jenna was a huge
part of all this.
So really a team effort, not
just me doing this at all,
but this was her full
time thing as well.
So the first place that I left
for was Antarctica, and Jenna
was ever steady at
the helm of running
our nonprofit and expedition
logistics in the background.
So this is the first
step on the journey.
I remember this small
plane landed me down
on the frozen continent.
And as you can see
from this photo,
the landscape out
there is crazy,
just desolate and
surreal, just white
in every single direction.
I describe it best as it feels
like standing inside the belly
of a ping pong ball.
Just really disorienting and
white everywhere you look.
And of course, I
had read about this,
but the extreme
cold was something
that I had never been privy to.
So it was so cold that
the average temperature
in Antarctica is
minus 40 degrees.
And what this picture
is, I've actually
taken a cup of boiling
water from my dinner
and thrown it into the air.
And it instantly turns into ice.
So that gives you a sense of
what minus 40 degrees feels
like on your body.
And as you saw from
the last photo,
I actually have all
my gear behind me
and I'm dragging in
a sled day by day
till I reached the South Pole.
On many of these journeys.
I was completely alone.
But on this journey,
I had a team with me
of a few other people.
So this is us inside of our
tiny little shelter of a tent,
kind of keep warm, put
a smile on our face.
And this next video shows kind
of the importance of teamwork
in such a hard and
harsh environment,
which is when you get out
of your tent in the morning,
it's minus 40.
There's no standing around.
Of course, this is a time
lapse, but over the course
of about five minutes,
we're packing everything up.
Everyone has a role,
putting it in our sleds,
and then quickly moving along.
Because if you stand around even
for a minute or two in minus 40
degrees, you can immediately get
hypothermic or get frostbite.
So having a really well oiled
machine of a team working.
And that's a theme throughout
this entire project.
Even in moments
when I was alone,
there was a team
in the background,
Jenna, et cetera, working
to make sure this all
somehow would hopefully work.
So I arrived on the middle of
January 2016 to the South Pole.
And when you arrived to
the first pole or mountain,
that's actually when the
official clock is starting.
So I'm now on the clock for the
world record going from here.
And so I'm going to run
through a few of the mountains.
Of course, not enough
time to tell you
stories about all
of them, although
every single expedition
itself has many stories.
But I'll tell you some longer
stories about Everest and stuff
after that.
But next up was
Mount Vinson, which
is the tallest
mountain in Antarctica.
This was me taking my mask
off for literally 10 seconds
to get a photo to
prove that I was there.
I'm trying to smile,
but it's actually
minus 70 degrees wind chill
on the summit of that peak.
And you can see my eyebrows
and eyelashes immediately
are iced up as I try to take
just one quick photo to prove
I was there.
Next up was Aconcagua,
the tallest mountain
in South America.
So forgive me if this is
review for some of you.
This is very smart room.
But on mountains, of course,
as you get to higher altitudes,
the oxygen remains the
same, but the pressure
being less dense, you
can breathe in less air
as you get up there, which means
your body needs to get used
to the thinner air to climb up.
If we got dropped off at
the top of Mount Everest,
for example, right
now from sea level,
we would die in about
two to three minutes,
because we would not be
able to breathe up there.
So that process of getting your
body used to higher altitudes
is called acclimatization.
But still at these
high altitudes,
so Aconcagua is the
tallest mountain
outside of the Himalayas
in the entire world,
or outside of
Asia, I should say.
22,874 feet.
So at the top of
there, I actually
was on this expedition
completely alone.
A random guy who I met climbing
down took this photo of me.
But as I'm up
there, I'm literally
walking at the pace of
one step every 15 seconds.
And even that up there
is you're cruising.
You're Usain Bolt up there
when you're moving like this.
It's pretty crazy what
it feels like to be
up at that high altitude.
But the one benefit of
climbing these mountains
as quickly as I was
was that I could be
acclimatized from one mountain.
Of course, I was getting more
and more tired fatigue wise,
but I'd be more acclimatized
going into the next mountain.
So it allowed me to climb some
of these mountains a little bit
quicker, which brings
us to Kilimanjaro.
Anybody in here
climb Kilimanjaro?
Couple of people.
All right.
What route did you come?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] .
COLIN O'BRADY: Nice.
Nice.
Very cool.
So as the couple of
you who have climbed
this mountain in this room
know, Kilimanjaro is generally
climbed in about a week.
It's 19,341 feet.
And that's very high, again, if
you're coming from sea level.
But I had just come
from Aconcagua,
and Kilimanjaro was the one
mountain that I had previously
climbed in the years past.
So in 2013 Jenna and I
climbed Kilimanjaro together.
And we climbed the Machame route
in about six days, I believe.
But I decided since
I was on the clock,
I wanted to see if I could climb
Kilimanjaro faster than that.
So I actually set
myself the goal
to see if I could climb
Kilimanjaro in a single day.
One single push from
the base to the summit.
And so Kilimanjaro has
some interesting rules,
because it's inside
of a national park
inside of Tanzania.
And so you're required,
even though I didn't really
need a guide per
se, you're required
to go with a local
guide, which is actually
a really great way of
creating jobs over there
and everything like that.
So we kind of went
back and forth dialogue
and I said, yeah, well
we've got a guy for you.
And I was like,
well make sure he
understands that I want to
try to climb this mountain
in one day.
Enter Frank.
Great guy.
I'm put with Frank.
I said, Frank, how many times
have you climbed Kilimanjaro?
He says, "I've climbed
Kilimanjaro 115 times.
You're in good hands."
You look at him, he's
a really strong guy,
super friendly, amazing guy.
We're having a blast together.
And I said, we're going to
try to climb it in one day.
What's the fastest you've
ever climbed it in?
And he said, "Out of 115
times, the fastest I've
climbed it is three
days, but I've always
wanted to see if I
could climb it one day."
So we set off and we're.
We're going super hard.
And the bottom
part is the jungle.
So it gets cold up high,
but you start at 5,000 feet,
so there's a significant
change of altitude
as well as temperature, climate.
Everything changes.
It's kind of a jungle to start,
with monkeys and everything
down the bottom.
And he takes off.
And before the first hour,
two hours, I am so exhausted.
I'm like, oh my
gosh, I'm an idiot.
I obviously bit off more
than I can chew here.
I thought I was super
strong, but this guy
is way stronger than me.
I'm trying to keep up, but
I'm sweating profusely.
And I'm finally
thinking to myself,
I'm going to have to
tell him, I don't know.
I'm not sure.
So we take a break.
We drink some water, eat
a little bit of food.
And I'm like, I'm not
going to say anything yet.
We're going to power
on for another hour.
Another hour goes
by and again, I'm
really kind of on
my last little rope.
I'm like, wow, this
guy is so strong.
I really overestimated
my abilities.
We get to the next break
and he says, oh hey,
can I borrow some of your water?
And I was like, all right.
We're three hours
into what I think
is going to be about a 12 or
15 hour day at the shortest.
And I was like, are
you out of water?
He's like, yeah, I
drank all of mine.
So I got to tell you something.
What's that?
He goes, so there's the
bet back at the hotel
that there's a 0%
chance you're going
to be able to climb
Kilimanjaro in a single day.
And they all paid me
to try to tire you out
as hard as I could in
the first few hours.
[LAUGHTER]
I actually didn't bring
enough food or water,
but you seem pretty determined.
I keep expecting you to
say we're going to stop,
and you're still chugging along.
And I was like, oh god.
Made me feel a
little bit better.
But then I was like,
wait, no water, no food?
Luckily I had thrown a
couple of extra energy gels
and bars in my backpack and
had a little bit of water.
The cat was out of the bag.
But unfortunately for him
and his betting buddies,
we did continue
onward to the summit
and made it to the
summit in 11 hours
from the base to the summit,
arriving at the night,
as you can see here.
So that was a funny chapter.
But Frank is an amazing guy.
We still stay in touch.
So after that, I went
off to Carstensz Pyramid,
which is the tallest
mountain in Australasia.
So there's sort of
somewhat of a controversy
whether Australia
the continent itself
or the sort of larger
region, depending
on where the tectonic
plates were, is the tallest.
So I actually climbed eight
instead of seven summits,
just because there's
two different lists.
So I climbed the tallest in
the Australian continent, which
is called Kosciusko, as
well as this mountain, which
is the tallest in
the larger region.
And as you can see
from that first video,
I think I'm trying to smile
here, but I'm very scared.
Let's be honest.
And then next up
was Mount Elbrus,
the tallest mountain in all
of Europe, which is in Russia.
That was a winter ascent,
almost always climbed in summer.
But I climbed it in winter
so that I could stay ahead
of the curve for the record.
The next place that I went
to was the North Pole.
And it's a little bit
counter intuitive.
So it's not something
that everyone is aware of.
Of course, when you think
about it, it's obvious.
But the North Pole,
of course there's
no land underneath
the North Pole.
It's just the Arctic
sea ice floating around
in the middle of
the ocean up there.
And so you're literally
walking around on ice.
Right below it is the ocean.
There's these cracks
in the sea ice
and it's getting worse
and worse, unfortunately,
because of climate
change, of course.
So much so that I was crossing
the last degree of latitude
and I had to arrange for
this Russian helicopter
to drop me off at my
starting point for me
to cross to the North Pole
and then come pick me up.
And for an extra
eight or nine days,
they couldn't find anywhere
to land because they kept
seeing this cracked sea ice.
And my partner who I
was out there with,
a guy by the name
of Eric Larson,
he actually fell through
the ice at one point
when we were there and had
to pull them out and keep
moving forward.
So it's a really
crazy environment.
And again, it's about
minus 40 degrees.
And why that's actually
particularly challenging
is that this brings
us to the final third.
So the last three
mountains or expeditions
where the North Pole, Everest,
and Denali, which a lot of ways
are the three most
challenging expeditions.
And then the North
Pole is at sea level.
And so me being delayed at
the North Pole at sea level
right before Everest
did the reverse of what
I was talking about
before being acclimatized,
and all of a sudden, I was
back acclimatized to sea level,
having been delayed,
and I needed
to climb next Mount
Everest, of course,
the tallest mountain in the
world, coming from sea level.
And because of that
delay and the way
the weather windows
overlap, I was actually
the very last person to
arrive to Mount Everest base
camp on the entire season.
So I arrived at
the end of April.
People normally
arrive to Everest
base camp, which
is at 17,000 feet,
around the first week of April.
And it's not like you
can say, oh great,
I showed up a month late.
I'll just summit a month later.
There's a very specific
weather window on Everest,
it's usually the second
or third week of May,
that it's even possible
to summit the mountains
when the jet stream
diverts from the peak
and you get this
tiny little moment
of lighter, I should say, winds.
Not light winds, lighter winds.
To try to get to the
top of the world.
So I was really
up against it now.
I'd been going 100 plus
days, hadn't taken a rest.
I was exhausted, and I
had now only three weeks
to climb Mount Everest rather
than the customary eight weeks
that it normally takes.
But this is what the
mountain looks like.
This is me standing
up around camp one.
So basically there's
base camp and then
four progressive camps
above that, aptly named
camp one, camp two,
camp three, camp four.
Very exciting names.
And then from camp four,
you go to the summit.
Again, the reason these
camps is at each camp
you get your body
a little bit used
to a little bit more thin air.
Some of you might know just
a little bit about Everest,
or read about it, but this
is the famous khumbu icefall.
In 2014, unfortunately about
15 or 16 sherpas, I believe,
died right here in this
spot due to an avalanche,
and that closed the
entire climbing season.
So no one summited
Everest that year at all.
And then in 2015,
of course, there
was the huge earthquake
in the country of Nepal
that devastated the country
as well as closed the climbing
season.
So in 2016 when I
was there, no one
had summited Everest from
Nepal in a couple of years.
And you can imagine as I
was going out and trying
to get people to
support this project,
people would say to
me, so wait, no one's
climbed Everest in
2014 or 2015 and you
think you're going to try
to climb Everest this year
and all these other mountains?
Good luck.
So it was very hard for me to
get support for this project
initially because
of the challenges
that Everest had had.
This is what it looks like
crossing one of these.
This is me with my
GoPro facing down.
So there is not just one
or two of these ladders
like this spanning crevasses.
But that's about a 300 or 400
foot drop off into an icy grave
down there.
And there's about 50 or 60
of these ladder crossings
throughout the khumbu
icefall, depending
on how it's all moving around.
So strangely, you
try to get sort
of used to this feeling of
crossing across this precipice.
But as you'll see,
I cheered every time
because I was just
excited to make it across.
Not above hooting and
hollering every time
I crossed one of those.
And so next up, the
challenge was something
called the lhotse face.
It's about a 5,000 foot, very
steep section of the mountain.
So I was climbing without
any guides, just myself
and a guy by the name
of [INAUDIBLE] who
was a sherpa who I had met
climbing in Nepal the year
previously.
And we realized that it
looked like there was
going to be a weather window.
So we thought there's a
very small weather window,
but let's see if we can skip
from camp two to camp four
directly, and then go up
to camp four and from there
to the summit.
And so this is us arriving
to camp four, which
is supposed to be our
summit day the next evening.
You climb through the
night to reach the summit.
And as you can see
here, I'm starting
to wear supplemental
oxygen at this point.
So I did use supplemental
oxygen for my summit
push, which about 98% of
people who summit Everest do.
And of course, with my
condensed time period,
there was definitely
no opportunity for me
to try to climb without
supplementary oxygen.
So this is called
the Geneva spur.
And it looks like it's a really
beautiful day, as the weather
window had predicted.
But in an instant, the
weather shifted, and about 50,
60 mile per hour
winds blew in on us
right after we took this photo.
There's no photos
of this, because it
was such a bad storm.
It took us two and a half
hours just to set up our tent
and get inside and try
to survive the night
at 26,000 feet.
Which 26,000 feet and above is
actually called the death zone.
And it's aptly named, because
the human body cannot survive
for very long above 26,000 feet.
And so we got in our tent
just to survive the night,
knowing full well that we
had no shot for the summit.
And this video I'm
going to show you is us
the next morning getting ready
to go down from the mountain.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I have to descend now because
I'm stuck in this wind storm.
[INAUDIBLE] clear sky.
The summit feels like
it's just right there,
but we're just getting blown
around way too much here.
Way to dangerous to risk
climbing up to the top right
now.
Just come down from
camp four after having
to turn around due to weather.
A lot of people, if they got
to four and they come down,
there's no going back for sure.
That's it for them.
That's a one way ticket.
But not for me.
Disappointing.
Really, really disappointing.
It appears I still have Everest.
I'm going up there soon, soon.
Yeah.
[END PLAYBACK]
COLIN O'BRADY: So
trying to give myself
a pep talk, as you can see.
I don't know how
convinced you are by that.
I'm not sure I am either.
And what I don't
realize actually
when I'm taking this video,
but I realized quickly
as I get back to my tent, is
that what you see on my cheek
there is the
beginning of frostbite
on my cheek from being
in that wind storm.
And so I'm actually in
even worse circumstance
than I realized at this point.
It's very rare that people
make more than one attempt
for the summit on Everest.
After weathering a
night at camp four,
generally that's enough to kind
of, obviously fatigue wise,
but also because
I showed you I was
starting to use
supplemental oxygen.
So you're using some
of your supplies,
which I've cached
high on the mountain,
and so it gets harder and
harder to go up there.
But luckily, a few days
later, another weather window
presented itself.
And because of
some people that we
knew having to
abort their climbs
due to their own sickness, there
were some extra oxygen bottles
cached on the mountains.
And so had to get
a little bit lucky,
but it gave me the opportunity
to at least give it
another shot.
And I felt like I put
so much into this.
I didn't know, again, if I
was going to able to make it,
but I owed it to myself to
give it my absolute best
shot to go back up there.
So again, climbed
back up to camp four.
This is camp four right
around 10 o'clock.
And those [INAUDIBLE]
are actually
other people's headlamps
going up towards the summit.
And honestly, the weather
window looked exactly the same
on the Doppler and
everything as the last one.
It looked like it could
be good, but I had also
just seen how fast the
weather had shifted.
And so I was in my tent
at this point, terrified.
And really doing the
only thing that I
could think to do
to calm myself down
is I reached for my satellite
phone and I called Jenna.
And I said Jenna, what
do you think I should do?
I saw how fast this can change.
I'm afraid people might
die up here tonight.
At the very least, there's going
to be significant frostbite
that occurs on the
mountain tonight because
of the extreme cold and
winds that were predicted.
And in an incredible
moment of bravery,
she really set aside her
own justifiable fears
and said to me what I needed
to hear in that moment.
She said to me something along
the lines of, Colin, people
are going to summit
Mount Everest tonight
and there is no reason that
you can't be one of them.
Go inside your body and listen.
Face your fears.
I know you can do it.
And that really gave me
the courage and strength
to get outside of my
tent and give it a shot.
As you can see, on
Everest, there's
one rope that goes up Everest
that all the teams together
have pooled together to help
put on the mountain which allows
people to be clipped
in and connected
to the mountain in
relative safety.
But the problem with
that is that it also
can create some traffic jams.
Which if you've
read about Everest,
you've probably
heard about that.
So as I said, no one had
climbed Everest in 2014,
no one had climbed
Everest in 2015,
and somehow I end
up on a summit day
the most crowded
day the mountain has
seen in over three years.
So there's about 100 people
going for the summit because
of these weather windows
that all condense people
onto this one day,
this one time.
It was certainly my last shot.
And so it [INAUDIBLE] and I
decided to get out of our tent
and go for it.
But we actually decided
that the safest option
is to not be clipped
to the rope at all,
but instead to walk
beside of these people.
So if we fell, we would be in
a dire set of circumstances.
But actually walking behind
in this slow line of people,
I demonstrated before how slow
I was walking on Aconcagua,
Everest is a whole other thing.
One step per minute is not
uncommon on the summit day,
even with supplementary oxygen.
And so to keep ourselves warm,
we felt like we
needed to keep moving.
And so we get up to
the top about where
those headlamps end, and we've
been unclip this whole time.
We safely climb up
there without any ropes.
And finally, we get to a
section where people are still
in front of us, but it's
too unsafe to be unclipped.
And so I take out
my last jacket,
actually I have one more
bigger layer to put on me,
I'm adjusting my
gloves a little bit.
And I look down and my right
hand is completely black.
Just black as
black can be, which
is a very telltale sign
of severe frostbite.
And I'm at about 28,000 feet
in altitude at this point,
much higher than I've ever been.
Brain's not working pretty well.
It's still a little
bit dark outside.
And I decide, I had this
very strange thought process,
which is, I'm not
particularly proud of,
I suppose, but I look at my
head and I'm like, well, I
guess my right hand is gone.
Is Jenna still going to love me?
[LAUGHTER]
And I thought,
well, maybe she'll
love me, even though I'm
going to lose my hand anyways,
if I at least get to
the summit of Everest
and then lose my right hand.
And so I decide to continue
onwards towards the summit.
And I don't tell [INAUDIBLE]
because he's a great climbing
partner, and if he had told
me his hand was like this,
I would have turned
him around immediately
and he would have certainly
done the same for me,
being a very smart and
savvy climbing partner.
And so we end up, again,
these are the kind
of lines that we ended up.
We're moving slowly and
the daylight finally rises.
And I decided, well
I should probably
capture this a little bit.
I'm trying to capture
this footage and things
for all the people following
along, particularly the kids.
They're using this inside
of their school curriculums
and interacting with us over
social media this entire time.
And so I get out my GoPro
to shoot this video, which
gives you a sense of what it
looks high up on the summit
ridge of Everest.
It was about 30 minutes
away from the summit.
That's [INAUDIBLE] there in
red and a few other climbers
in front of us near a section
called the Hillary Step, which
is maybe not there anymore.
And as you can see, it's
an incredible place.
Despite the situation
with my hand,
I was just inspired by the view
and everything I could see.
And because I'm messing
around with my camera
and I've got these big
huge mitten and gloves
on, I should say first, the
one other thing that I had done
is I have heated foot
warmers inside of my boots.
And so when I saw
my hand like this,
I turned my heated foot
warmers up as high as possible
because I'm thinking, I didn't
notice my hand being this cold.
Who knows what my
feet look like?
But I just cranked
those up as high
as possible to at least be like,
well, they're at least warm.
And as I do this with my camera,
I adjust my gloves around again
and I look down at my hand.
And all of a sudden, I'm
like, my hand's back.
My hand's back!
And [INAUDIBLE] looks back
at me from that ridge.
He's like, Colin,
premature celebration.
The summit is still just there.
And I was like, no
man, my hand's back.
He's like, what are
you talking about?
Because I hadn't
told him, of course.
And it just so happened
that I had chemical hand
warmers in my gloves
and they had broken open
and the charcoal and copper
from the chemical hand warmers
had dyed my hand black.
But my hand was completely fine.
And so thank god I
didn't find that out
back down at camp four,
having descended off
the mountain in the
middle of the night,
but instead I found it a few
steps away from the summit.
And so my celebration
was slightly premature.
But about 30 minutes
later, we ended up
at this moment, which is an
unforgettable moment for me.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I'm on the summit of Mount
Everest, top of the world.
No words can describe.
These two guys right
here [INAUDIBLE]..
Top of the world!
[END PLAYBACK]
COLIN O'BRADY: So full of
elation in that moment.
And I mentioned the
social media before.
And as you know, I set two
world records ultimately.
But there's another record that
I don't get enough credit for.
I think Guinness
should add this one.
But I was actually also
the very first person
to Snapchat from the
summit of Mount Everest.
So there that is.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Summit of Mount Everest!
[END PLAYBACK]
COLIN O'BRADY: And
that was pretty fun,
but all jokes aside,
that actually ultimately
was the most viewed Snapchat
story of all of 2016.
And because of the work
we were doing with kids,
they were able to see a look
into it in real time, which
is a really fun way,
one of the many ways
we were sharing this story,
but actually using technology
on the summit of Mount
Everest to give people
an eye into it in real
time was super fun for us,
particularly with the age
demographic that uses Snapchat.
So anyways, we make
it to the summit.
And that was just an incredible
moment for me and a childhood
dream, really, a mountain I'd
always dreamed about climbing.
So safely descending back down
the mountain back to camp four,
I crawled back into
my tent at camp four
and I reached for
my satellite phone
to call Jenna again
to tell her the news.
And she was like,
how are you doing?
Did you make it?
I was like, yes, I made it,
no frostbite, no injuries.
I'm exhausted, but I'm good.
And then I said, well actually,
I actually burned my feet.
And she said, what?
We've actually been
getting some reports.
She'd been following
on social media
that there's a lot of frostbite.
And actually about 25 people
over the next three days
were evacuated off the mountain
with extreme frostbite.
And two people, not whom I
knew or were climbing with,
did pass away that
night on the mountain.
So unfortunately, my
premonition had been correct,
really putting into perspective
how intense it can be up there
and the risks you're taking.
But she said to me, wait, I
thought you said no frostbite?
I said, yeah, no, I
actually burned my feet.
So I had turned my
boot warmers up so warm
that I had actually burned
two little small circles
in the bottoms of my feet.
And she was like,
you're an idiot.
Your feet, fire.
You're the only idiot that
goes and climbs Mount Everest,
doesn't get frostbite, but
actually burns your feet.
She then said something that
I will never, ever in my life
forget.
She says, so Colin, I actually,
despite the burnt feet
and everything, I need you
to put your boots back on.
And I was like, what?
It just took me an hour
to take my boots off,
crawl in my tent [INAUDIBLE].
What are you talking about?
She goes, well, we've been doing
some calculations back home,
and it just so
happens that if you
can summit Denali
in the next week,
you have a chance to set not
one, but two world records.
So she goes, so I need to
put your boots back on,
climb all the way back down
to base camp right now.
I've arranged for a
helicopter that'll
pick you up in base camp and
it will fly you to Kathmandu.
There's not enough time for
you to spend a night in a hotel
or take a shower or anything,
but an evening flight
would take you from Dubai
to Seattle to Anchorage,
and then you'll have about
three days to climb Denali.
I know normally takes
about three weeks,
but I think you can do it.
And maybe I just know well
enough to not say no to her,
or the competitive juices in me
were flowing sure nonetheless.
But somehow, just 100
hours after standing
on the summit of
Mount Everest, I
arrived to Alaska to attempt
my final mountain, Denali.
And so Denali in itself is
an incredibly hard mountain
to climb.
It's 20,000 feet high.
Alaska is known
for extreme weather
and there's no support
on the mountain.
So you're dragging huge,
heavy amounts of weight.
I'm dragging a sled and a
huge full backpack here.
And my old friend
Tucker Cunningham,
who was a friend of mine who
I grew up with in Portland,
met me to be my climbing
partner on the last mountain.
So it was great to see him,
and he was at least a little
bit more energized than
I was, having just flown
across the world.
And I've been going 130
some days at this point.
I'm pretty worked.
So we get up about
halfway on Denali.
We have 24 hours left
to try to get to the top
to set the second
world record, which
is the record for the Seven
Summits, not the Explorers
Grand Slam.
But I was two months ahead
of the Explorers Grand Slam
at this point.
And we get up and
all of a sudden,
we're putting our
tent up, and then
this is what the
weather turns to.
That's Tucker.
I was filming, but
my thoughts exactly.
Pretty well sums
it up right there.
And so we say, OK, we've
got to go to bed and wake
up in the morning.
We've got this one shot
to get to the summit.
Maybe the winds will die down.
Alaska historically is
known for these storms
coming in and lasting
not just a day,
but usually a week or 10 days.
And so we said, well, maybe
we'll get lucky this time.
Let's go to sleep,
wake up in the morning,
and see what the
weather is doing.
Maybe we'll have one
Hail Mary pass to go.
So this next video is
me filming myself inside
of my tent the next morning.
The audio is not great, but
it's subtitled, so bear with me.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
COLIN O'BRADY: Now
there's a pump up talk
if you've ever seen one, right?
Let's go to the summit.
Let's go.
So I'm thinking, OK, I'm not
hearing too much wind outside.
I think it's died
down, whatever.
I get outside of my tent and
this is what it looks like.
I think there's snow
over my tent or something
and I'm not hearing this or
I've got my ear plugs in.
But basically, the snow and
wind have not died down at all.
And so it's decision time.
And at this point, I said,
Tucker, what do you want to do?
And he said, hey,
I'm here for you.
You tell me what you want to do.
And there's a quote that
I love, which is often
contributed to Confucius,
although some people say
Henry Ford said it.
I like to think that
it was Confucius
long before Henry Ford.
But a paraphrase of both.
It's a quote goes
something along the lines
of, "He who says he
can and he says he
can't are both usually right."
And so I said to
Tucker, do you think we
can climb for 15 minutes today?
And he says, yeah, I mean
we're at least 12 hours
below the summit, but sure,
let's put our stuff on.
I'm here for you.
Let's go out in the
storm and see how we go.
So we put all of our stuff
on, we're hiking out of camp.
A guy from another camp
actually unzips his tent,
sticks his head outside,
and he says, hey,
are you guys bailing off,
getting down the mountain
from the storm?
I hear it's going
to last 10 days.
We're thinking
about leaving too.
And we're like, no, no,
we're going for the summit.
And the guy's like,
get back in your tent.
No one's climbing today.
And sure enough, we
were the only people
that even tried to move
anywhere on the mountain
this entire day.
15 minutes goes by
and we check in.
I said, how are your hands?
How are your feet?
How are you feeling?
He says yeah, I'm
still pretty good.
How are you?
I'm like, I'm
exhausted obviously,
but I can keep going.
Let's go another 15.
15 turns 30.
Another 30 turns into an hour.
You see where this is going.
About three hours in
the day, this happens,
which is that my pants
that I've been now wearing
for about 139 days straight,
these GORE-TEX pants,
the zippers completely
get blown off of them
and now my leg is
exposed to about 50,
60 mile per hour winds, minus
60 degree wind chill ish.
And so we're on the side of
this mountain, trying to duct
tape my pant leg up.
And my watch, which I haven't
taken off in four days,
the watch strap breaks
and falls on the ground.
And so literally the wheels
are just falling off the bus.
My equipment is breaking.
I don't know what's going on.
But I'm like, we
got to keep going.
This is our one shot.
I don't even know if I
have another attempt in me.
And we keep going, hour
by hour, hour by hour,
and after 12 hours after leaving
in a huge storm on Denali,
we reached this moment,
which is my finish
line, the summit of Denali.
That's me in yellow there,
taking the last few steps
after 139 days.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[WHOOPING]
- I'm a world record holder!
Two times!
[END PLAYBACK]
COLIN O'BRADY: I think his line
after that was something like,
and he's modest too, ladies!
But I'm a little bit
delirious, as you can tell.
I'm trying to express
my elation in some way,
but you can see
this look in my eye.
It's mostly just pure and utter
exhaustion, complete fatigue
after all of this, but a moment
that I will absolutely cherish
for the rest of my life.
Just a special
moment to celebrate
not just my hard work,
but the hard work
of so many other people
that went into this.
Jenna supporting
this with every ounce
of her being throughout
this entire two year process
at this point.
And really reaching that moment
was a special thing for me
personally.
But really this project,
like I said before,
and to kind of bring us back
in this room a little bit,
was so much more than just
me going out into the world
and trying to pat myself on
the back for setting two world
records.
The media arc of all
of this was exciting.
300, 400 or 500
million earned media
impressions by at this
point around the story.
And this was covered widely.
But the reason that was
mostly important to me
was it gave us a vehicle to
speak at schools, to talk
to kids about setting goals.
And it's really been amazing
to see this grow honestly
beyond my wildest
dreams, from just an idea
that Jenna and I had in
our apartment in Portland,
and grow into this global feat,
which was somehow successful.
I still kind of can't believe
that we actually pulled it off.
But it has allowed
us this opportunity
to speak and share this
story with you and in many
different of these forums.
And one of my favorite
things that we
did with the kids that was a
great part of this project,
Jenna actually came up with it
while I was climbing Everest
and it has lived on now
in our nonprofit work,
is asking kids this question,
which is, what is your Everest?
Asking this gymnasium
room full of kids
and they all raise their hand,
because they're so excited.
I love kids, because
they love to participate.
It's a little harder
with adults sometimes.
But they raise their hands
and they say amazing things.
And that was not just
in person, but actually
while I was climbing
Everest, you
saw that I was Snapchatting.
They were sending us videos
and it was a two way dialogue
while I was out
there that was being
brought into these curriculums.
And kids would say
amazing things.
They'd say, my Mount
Everest is to be
the first person in my family
to graduate from college.
Or my Mount Everest is to
be a doctor or an engineer.
Or one of my favorites
was, my Mount Everest
is to make sure that the
snow leopards stay off
the endangered species list.
Just the different
ways that kids
would imagine asking and
thinking about big goals.
And so I want to close
this by something that's
a metaphor that
really sticks with me,
and because I think although
I do a lot of work with kids,
I think this is a pertinent
example to everyone.
It's certainly pertinent to me.
And the metaphor is this.
So I carry this small rock
with me every single day.
And it's a small rock from
the summit of Mount Everest.
And for me, this rock stands
for that moment in the hospital
when I chose to keep
pushing forward.
And this rock also stands
for my untapped potential.
Because as I said,
set goals in my life
and ultimately
encounter obstacles,
this rock reminds me that even
Mount Everest, the biggest
mountain in the world,
can be broken down
to its smallest parts.
A bunch of small rocks
stacked on top of each other.
Many steps leading
to the summit.
Maybe right now in
your day to day life,
you're just feeling
overwhelmed, it's too much.
Or maybe here at Google you're
creating some incredible ideas
or thinking about
innovations, but there's
people around you saying,
oh, that's not possible,
that's not going to work.
Or maybe you've
been badly injured
in an accident at some
point in your life
and you're feeling like
you can't make it forward.
You're not going to be
able to fully recover.
Tragedy and other great
obstacles befall all of us.
I don't care who you are.
And in those moments, our
minds are flooded with doubt.
We ask ourselves these
questions like, why me?
Is this even possible?
Should I give up?
And our mindset,
of course, shifts
to this negative
moment, the same as me
in that Thai hospital.
But what I learned from
that and what we all
know is that those
negative mindset,
we do not have to stay there.
The only question that matters
when facing great obstacles
is how will you respond?
You have a choice.
And when you shift your
mindset towards the positive,
you will realize that all
of us have these reservoirs
of untapped potential
waiting to be released
by us switching that mindset.
I don't think that I am any sort
of superhuman athletic freak
or anything like this.
I think I'm just a
regular guy from Portland.
But I can confidently
tell you this.
Achievement is not
for the select few.
Achievement is just simply
for those who never quit.
It is for those who
set goals and it
is for those who put the most
steps in front of the others.
Achievement is for those who
overcome the biggest obstacle
of all, their own minds.
So in closing, I
would say, set a goal.
Take the first steps.
The chair is right
in front of you.
And when your steps get you
there, push the chair further.
When you feel like giving
up, put your boots back on.
Let go of fear.
Remember this story
and remember this rock,
and watch as your rocks stack
up to the summit of your Mount
Everest.
Thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Any questions?
Happy to answer any questions.
I really appreciate
you guys being here.
AUDIENCE: First question.
When it comes to
the polls, I mean
the mountain's pretty clear
where you start at the bottom
and you end at the top.
How does it work for the polls?
COLIN O'BRADY: Yeah
very good question.
So I don't make these
rules, obviously.
But for the
Explorers Grand Slam,
the way that the
record is measured
is that you need to cross
at least the last degree
of latitude by
your own manpower.
And so I was dropped off at
the 89th degree at both poles
and crossed the last degree,
which is 69 nautical miles.
AUDIENCE: What is next for you?
Because the chair is pretty
far ahead of you right now.
So what are you going to do?
COLIN O'BRADY: I have
a couple other projects
that I'm working on.
I still think of myself,
of course, as an athlete.
I'm 32 years old, and so
there's a couple other big world
record breaking
projects that I'm
going to have to be coy about
and not quite announce here
on this stage, but very soon.
Please follow along with
me, social whatever,
because I'll be announcing
that very soon what those are.
But also it's been a
great joy for me, honestly
this project in terms of the
arc and the exposure of it,
has grown beyond
my wildest dreams,
and it's been amazing
to have the opportunity
over the last year
to share this story,
both in a corporate
format like this as well
as with kids and the
nonprofit work that I do.
And so that's been a huge focus.
I'm working on a book.
And I know sometimes people
come here on the Google stage
to promote their book,
so maybe I can come back
when my book is out next year.
But there's a lot of
things in the work.
But with everything I do,
even these next world record
big projects for me,
of course, there's
a huge piece of me that
loves pushing my own body.
But the storytelling part
of it and the ability
to use that as a vehicle to
motivate and inspire others
will always be sort of
a bedrock of what I do.
Yeah.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Are you planning on
trying for K2 or Annapurna?
COLIN O'BRADY: No.
Great question.
So a little
mountaineering backstory,
for those of you who don't know
what those two mountains are.
But there are 14 8,000 meter
peaks, which are the 14 tallest
mountain in the world,
of course Everest
being the tallest of them and
K2 being the second tallest,
and Annapurna being the
most dangerous of them all.
And so there is a kind of
a holy grail of climbing,
only one American has
ever accomplished it,
to climb all 14
8,000 meter peaks.
So I'd be lying to tell you
if I had never thought of it.
It's certainly in
the back of my mind.
I fashion myself
as a mountaineer
and I love climbing mountains,
but as these other projects,
as you'll see as
unveil, there's some
will have mountain
components, but there's
some that are completely
outside the mountain.
So not just in the
mountains is what I do.
Sort of endurance
sports and really
finding my own personal
limits in many different ways
is what I'm passionate about.
All right, well thank
you guys so much.
I really, really appreciate it.
This has been a great
pleasure for me to be here.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]